[Musique]
chapelle ardente à montigny le
bretonneux pour un dernier hommage aux
victimes de l'avalanche le guide de
haute montagne qui encadraient la
randonnée a été placé en garde à vue un
demi million de fidèles à cuba sur la
place de la révolution pour la messe
célébrée par jean paul ii e melli
politique du saint père la contre
attaque de bill clinton qui réunit à
cabinet de crise alors que la presse
s'arrachent les images du président avec
la jeune stagiaire
l'extrême gauche occurred les opérations
spectaculaires des chômeurs en quête
dans ce journal avec l'exemple d'une
action commando dans un centre voeckler
enfin découverte avec le cirque de
demain en piste le talent et la fougue
de ces acrobates de numéros
spectaculaires
madame monsieur bonsoir la douleur
rapproche et unis les habitants de
montigny le bretonneux venus s'incliner
devant les cercueils des collégiens et
de leurs professeurs entraîné dans la
mort vendredi dernier de nombreux jeunes
parfois une fleur à la main se sont
rendus à la chapelle ardente installée
dans le gymnase pierre de coubertin
pascal douce et bon olivier robert
une longue colonne dans le froid
silencieuse et tête baissée
l'affluence n'a pas fléchi toute la
journée elle a surpris les autorités
montigny voulait communier dans le deuil
le calme et les larmes
qu'il était innocent ils ont suivi
les professeurs et les encadrants
étaient conscients
ils décident toujours confiance ces
cultes
complètement si on leur a dit suivre ils
sont suivis moi j'ai pas les mots pour
le dire j'ai de la peine pour les
camarades d'école
il y fait chaud nous avons une classe de
neige elle est rentrée
peut-être que nous sommes surpris par le
moment où delà des preuves la vie
continue l'espoir et demi
il fait froid alors le maire de montigny
s'improvise organisateurs ouvrir une
salle chauffée de plus demandé un
renfort de policiers et pendant ce temps
le gymnase ne désemplit pas
les neuf corps des élèves de saint
françois et d'un de leurs professeurs
resteront là jusqu'à mardi pour recevoir
l'hommage de leur ville
le principal lui a réuni les familles de
la quatrième est à l'abri des regards
pour les réconforter et leur assurer que
lui aussi veut des réponses
dossier et on fera les démarches
juridiques nécessaires
pour savoir exactement ce qui s'est
passé hors de nos caméras un père de
famille parle de dépôt de plainte les
professeurs aussi se réunissent au
collège ils ont pour consigne de ne pas
s'exprimer il prépare la rentrée de
demain début des cours peu après 9h
malgré tout
du côté de l'anc est le guide de haute
montagne qui encadraient la randonnée
qui aurait mal apprécier les risques a
été entendu plusieurs fois par les
gendarmes cet après midi daniel forte 43
ans a été placé en garde à vue ce guide
considéré comme un professionnel
expérimenté se dit en état de choc par
la voix de son épouse philippe
visseyrias hier midi discrètement daniel
forte a quitté son domicile dans une
voiture de gendarmerie
ce guide de haute montagne qui
encadraient la randonnée meurtrière est
au centre de l'enquêté
aujourd'hui depuis 14h30 il est placé en
garde à vue
le juge d'instruction sera saisi par mes
soins d'une information judiciaire sur
la base des textes réprimant l'homicide
involontaire les blessures involontaires
et la mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
il d'après invitation qui m'ont été
fournies monsieur fortès comporte comme
une personne
désireuse d'apporter son concours à la
manifestation de la vérité et désireuse
de ne pas fuir ses responsabilités
on n'en sait donc un peu plus sur les
origines du drame le groupe parti
vendredi matin du refuge de la draille
avait pris du retard sur son programme
il devait rejoindre dans l'après-midi un
autobus qui attendait dans un village de
l'autre côté de la crête du lauzet au
moment du drame vers 13h30 les enfants
marché les uns derrière les autres
perpendiculairement à la pente
les premiers en particulier donc le
guide qui est en tête ont été plus ou
moins épargnés puisque ils étaient bien
en avant les autres plusieurs mètres en
contrebas ont pris de plein fouet des
blocs de neige pesant jusqu'à 200 kg
pour l'instant seul le guide pourrait
être mise en examen même si plus d'une
vingtaine de personnes ont été entendues
le directeur de l'office du tourisme d
or connais daniel portait il prend sa
défense
c'est quelqu'un qui est très connu qui
est très apprécié c'est ce qu'on peut
appeler un guide expérimenté c'est
quelqu'un qui a une quarantaine d'années
c'est loin d'être quelqu'un de tout fou
c'est quelqu'un qui est père de famille
d'un homme qui est passionné par son
métier par faire découvrir la montagne
aux jeunes vendredi dernier le guide at
il commis une erreur fatale c'est ce que
recherchent les gendarmes chargés de
l'enquêté
c'est demain que s'ouvrira à perpignan
le procès de patrick tissier décrit par
les experts comme un pervers sexuel aux
pulsions meurtrières après plus de
quatre ans d'instruction patrick tissier
violeur et assassin de la petite karine
huit ans comparaît devant les assises
des pyrénées orientales l'homme est
également jugé pour un autre meurtre et
une tentative d'assassinât sur une femme
qui l'a laissée pour morte valérie
ermite josé boulesteix
le soir du 21 septembre 93 lorsque les
enquêteurs investi cette bastide ils
savent qu'il n'ya plus lieu d'espérer au
fond d'un puits le corps de la petite
karine wolker 8 ans disparue depuis neuf
jours violet assassiné son meurtrier
tout juste interpellé est passé aux
aveux patrick tissier un multi
récidiviste était devenu un ami de la
famille dans l'après-midi du 13
septembre il va chercher karine à
l'école elle n'en reviendra jamais
tissier expliquera son geste par une
pulsion une envie subite de violer au
début je n'arrivais pas à croire que
c'était lui qui avait pré karine j'ai
toujours douté j'ai dit non ce pur
possible notre four était gentil gland
toujours journée des enfants et non il a
toujours été correct je suis dit non
c'est pas lui c'est pas possible il a
même pas de peine il a même pas de
chagrin pour lui c'était comme s'ils
avaient fait quelque chose comme un
gamin qui avait cassé un jouet
on n'arrive pas comprendre ça on ne peut
pas imaginer qu'un être humain est
normal qu'ils puissent faire une chose
pareille
la maman de karim ne connaissait alors
ni le passé ni la dangerosité de l'homme
qu'elle côtoyait déjà condamné deux fois
pour meurtre et pour viol fils y est
tout juste sorti de prison savait se
rendre aimable
marie-josée goze porte encore les
lourdes séquelles de sa rencontre avec
tissier elle est l'une des rares
rescapées de sa folie meurtrière
elle aussi était en toute confiance
jusqu'au 10 septembre à 93 un moment
donné il s'approche de moi qui m'étais
j'ai envie de coucher avec toi et c'est
parti comme ça c'est comme ça je le
refuse et encore je le raconte je le vis
et tous les jours celle de vie et à rien
et rien qui nous a échappé c'est quelque
chose qui est marquée qui est ancré dans
ma tête je n'ai que ça dans la tête
étranglée estropiés marie-josée go a
frôlé la mort mais elle tient
aujourd'hui affronter son agresseur dans
le box tissier qui quelques jours
auparavant avait également violé et tué
compte fait allez massa voisine de
palier de meurtre et une tentative en un
mois pour les psychiatres il n'aurait
aucun remord et serait incurable tissier
lui rétorque qu'il n'a jamais été ni
aidé ni suivi pendant ou après la prison
ce sont ces crimes et son parcours qui
ont inspiré une nouvelle loi la
perpétuité réelle pour les violeurs et
meurtriers d'enfants
à cuba sur la place de la révolution
lieu hautement symbolique un demi
million de personnes pour assister à la
messe célébrée par jean paul ii une
melli politique où les mots de justice
et de liberté sont souvent revenu dans
la bouche du saint-père l'esprit dit il
souffle sur cuba reportage à l'âme
salvan
elle était pleine la plage de la
révolution cinq cent mille personnes et
enthousiastes un enthousiasme
communicatif que fidel castro lui-même
au premier brand semble apprécier le
pape aussi il reporte à la foule
renversant le slogan qu'on lui scandent
samedi dont cuba à nous le pape est avec
toi c'est ce qu'on appelle la manière
pontificale que son trait les foules et
ça marche le pape ne peut aligner deux
phrases des fuites sans être interrompu
et ils en redemandent
je ne suis pas contre les
applaudissements quand vous applaudissez
le pape veut un peu se reposer
le discours lui même est un
chef-d'oeuvre déquilibre le pape renvoie
dos à dos le système ultralibéral la
toute puissance des marchés qui je cite
provoque un appauvrissement croissante
de tant de pays et le système communiste
avec son athéisme ces atteintes aux
droits de l'homme et à la liberté de
conscience
en recevant mercredi dernier jean paul
ii à l'aéroport de la havane fidel
castro lui avait dit de parler sans
retenue et le pape naturellement ne s'en
est pas privé il a exprimé toutes ces
idées lors certaines vont dans le sens
de castro par exemple la levée de
l'embargo où le discours contre le
libéralisme effréné d'autres en revanche
sont ici comme des tabous brisés
on ne parlait pas des droits de l'homme
on ne parlait pas de liberté de
conscience on ne parlait pas de
prisonniers politiques et l'accueil
extraordinaire du public vous l'entendez
derrière moi montre bien et devant
castro que c'était le discours que l'on
attendait ici à cuba
et puis en turquie un ancien militant
d'extrême droite a été arrêté soupçonné
par la police italienne d'être le
deuxième homme dans l'attentât contre le
pape jean paul ii en 1981 il était sur
le point de quitter le pays aux etats
unis bill clinton prépare sa riposte le
président vient de se constituer un
cabinet de crise bien décidé à garder
son fauteuil
désormais la contre attaque se veut
politique avec une semaine décisive
puisque mardi bill clinton fera le
traditionnel discours de l'état de
l'union devant le congrès ambiance à
washington autour de la maison blanche
avec pour principal souci aujourd'hui
les nouvelles images du président et de
monica levinsky ensemble maryse burgot
bill clinton saluons chaleureusement
monica levinsky
cette image d'as de 1996 nous sommes au
lendemain de la réélection du président
américain bill clinton est un homme
heureux il échange quelques mots avec
cette élégante jeune femme qu'il semble
connaître
l'image ne prouve absolument rien mais
elle a le parfum du scandale qui a
transformé la maison blanche en état de
siège et pendant que les télévisions
diffusent cette image en boucle le
président quitte l'église où il vient
d'assister à la messe comme tous les
dimanches matin
bill clinton et son épouse donne au
public l'image d'un couple uni
affrontant ensemble la tourmente
est pour l'instant le président
américain laisse à ses proches le soin
de le défendre sur les plateaux de
télévision nbc cnn cbs les grands
network ont aujourd'hui l'un ou l'autre
de ses conseillers sur leur plateau la
riposte a commencé
celui ci dénonce la folie médiatique
autour de l' affaire et rappelle que la
présomption d'innocence s'applique aussi
au président
la riposte s'organise enfin derrière les
murs de la maison blanche deux ex
conseiller de clinton vient d'être
rappelé en renfort dont nick et cantor
ancien secrétaire d'état au commerce
cet homme devra entre autres trouver la
bonne réponse à la dernière allégation
en date le fait que clinton aurait été
surpris par un ou des témoins lors d'une
de ces rencontres intimes avec monica
levinsky mika cantor a la réputation
d'être un négociateur de premier ordre
il a aussi la confiance absolue du
président si ce brillant avocat a été
rappelé ici à la maison blanche c'est
pour peaufiner point par point la
défense du président car chacun c'est
ici que les jours qui viennent seront
déterminants pour son avenir
deuxième jour de la visite d'état de
jacques chirac en inde une journée plus
politique avec à new delhi la rencontre
des principaux dirigeants du pays
reportage philippe harrouard
en se promenant à new delhi finirait par
penser que l'inde est immuable vieille
civilisation marquée par son passé
colonial empêtré dans ses traditions et
ses contradictions inde du mahatma
gandhi apôtre de la non-violence
victimes de la violence qui a été
incinéré ici rh
4-1 dans la population grouillante le
milliard sera bientôt dépassé
ou la misère s'étale dans les rues un
indien sur deux est analphabète
mais il y à notre phase celle d'une
nation entrer dans le modernisme par des
réformes audacieuses
libéralisation économique
ouverture au monde extérieur est celle
d'une démocratie qui n'a jamais
chanceler malgré l'instabilité politique
une aide que ses dirigeants veulent y
c'est demain dans les premiers rangs
d'économie mondiale jacques chirac est
venu dire sa confiance dans cette inde
là et son désir de mieux coopérer avec
elle
c'est une nouvelle ère leurs relations
de l'inde et la france doivent ouvrir
aujourd'hui
ambitieux audacieux
confiant notre partenariat doivent
embrasser notre temps et s'inscrire dans
l'histoire côté indien on se dit
intéressé par la main tendue de la
france pour accroître un partenariat
jugé jusqu'à présent trop timide en tout
cas pas la hauteur des responsabilités
que chaque pays entend assumer au niveau
mondial nouveaux massacres en algérie
vingt personnes assassinées dans le sud
ouest du pays dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche une tuerie qui s'est déroulée
dans un petit hameau et ce à quelques
jours de la fin du ramadan
en france à la veille d'une semaine deux
politiques importantes lionel jospin
pour la première fois malmené par les
sondages défend les choix du
gouvernement pour le coup d'envoi de la
campagne du parti socialiste sur les 35
heures le premier ministre appelle à la
cohésion de sa majorité
françoise david jacques garnich des
militants qui se pressent pour se
procurer le nouveau best seller de leur
parti c'était ce matin le lancement de
la campagne du parti
liste pour les élections régionales et
cantonales axe prioritaire la réduction
du temps de travail et pour que nuit
l'on n'ignore rien 80 pages de
graphiques et l'explication c'est la
nouvelle bible des socialistes à un
moment où lionel jospin enregistre une
baisse dans les sondages ce qui
semble-t-il n'affecte pas le moral
gouvernement quand ils sont bons je me
méfie et quand ils sont moins bons je me
dis va contester sale goût de gouverner
c'est pas un long fleuve tranquille
c'est normal quand il ya une crise à un
moment donné aussi
limité soit elle à un secteur d'activité
lorsque le pays pendant un certain temps
se pose des questions il est normal que
le gouvernement en subissent les
conséquences momentanée une fois encore
le premier ministre a affirmé que céder
aux pressions des chômeurs aurait
compromis totalement la politique
approuvée en juin dernier par les
français et il a appelé la majorité
plurielle à être solidaires devant le
peuple ils font qu'ils soient persuadés
que certes la diversité est là parce que
la diversité l'enrichît le rassure mais
qu il y a une grande orientation qui est
fixé qui fait une synthèse et qui par là
même constitue un cap la suite du débat
sur les 35 heures ce sera mardi à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
n'a pas l'espoir de convaincre
l'opposition mais il a la ferme
intention de trouver unis derrière lui
sans exception tous les députés de la
majorité
et puis je vous rappelle le rendez vous
politique de la rédaction mots croisés
de m'asseoir qui aura pour thème les 35
heures le mouvement des chômeurs avec
face à face martine aubry edouard
balladur une émission animée par arlette
chabot et al hadj ahmed alors que la
manifestation nationale des chômeurs est
prévue mardi prochain je vous propose
maintenant cette radioscopie sur les
actions commandos qui ont lieu ces
dernières semaines qui encadrent ces
opérations ultra médiatique quels sont
les âmes et les organisations qui gère
avec les chômeurs ses actions
spectaculaires
la réponse avec daniel wolfromm et
jacques garnissent
le scénario est toujours le même depuis
un mois plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants sillonnent les couloirs du
métro parisien seuls quelques
responsables connaissent l'objectif du
périple les médias suivent donc sans
savoir où le groupe se dirige le
militant de base par sécurité n'est pas
non plus mis dans la confidence
khlie témoin ne s'est pas dominer
vainqueur
marc un doctorat mais il est sans emploi
depuis quatre ans affirme utile et
milite dans une association de lutte
contre le chômage
jamais avoir signé aucun cas à aucun
mouvement
[Musique]
en revanche ce jour là dans le groupe
ses voisins sont des militants
anarchistes
et enceinte quand même 30 et vous
étudiants et vous
oui les patates une demi heure plus tard
l'objectif de la manifestation apparaît
enfin
c'est le supermarché leclerc de pantin
en seine-saint-denis
aussitôt pour éviter tout débordement
des militants plus organisés s'interpose
entre les vigiles du magasin et
l'essentiel de la troupe
locale
il faut éviter toute plainte pour vol
les organisateurs du mouvement tente un
repli derrière les caisses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord bonjour ma vie je suis chômeur
indemnisé par dieu et vous monsieur
éventuellement
le but de cette action était en fait une
réquisition pure et simple de
marchandises souhaitant négocier avec
nous la sortie d'un certain nombre de
cadeaux gratuits bas qui remplissent les
caddies quai dans la redite ensemble et
puis apparaît donc bien aucun problème
il va le rester on paie pour ça qu'ils
étaient à côté de labrecque
pour faciliter
la guérison le père n'a pas l'intention
de porter plainte les manifestants
sortent avec l'équivalent d'environ 5000
francs de produits divers
l'opération est un succès mais
christophe aguiton responsable du
mouvement ac est par ailleurs membre de
la ligue communiste révolutionnaire
préfère passer la parole à
l'organisatrice de cette action
cette redistribution de produits va
durer une dizaine de minutes devant le
trottoir du magasin
fonctionne
maintenant on est hésitant certains sont
mi-temps d'orientation politique qui
soutient le mouvement des chômeurs
politique
nous n'en saurons pas plus comme si
l'extrême gauche ne souhaitait pas trop
apparaître derrière des mouvements qui
se veulent avant tout rassembleur et
généreux et qui se présentent comme des
robins des bois des temps modernes
l'immense succès des téléphones
portables encourage des français a
demandé une réglementation pour usage de
ces téléphones qui sonnent partout et
n'importe quand c'est ce que révèle un
sondage paru ce week-end agir pour
empêcher les nuisances du portable
patricia charnelet clément ce gel oui au
téléphone portable non à cette
insupportable de sonneries qui agacent
les français au spectacle au restaurant
dans les transports bref nos concitoyens
plébiscitent ce petit objet près de 6
millions d'utilisateurs mais ne veulent
plus entendre en tout cas quand ce n'est
pas le leur çà et là pourtant la
résistance s'organise première concernée
les salles de spectacle dès l'entrée du
palais des congrès à paris vous êtes
prévenu il faut couper le mobile chéri
de plus une annonce est faite au début
de chaque spectacle
nous demandons au public d'éteindre leur
portable
la réussite d'un spectacle dans une
salle comme la nôtre est difficile et
bien sûr dû au talent de l'artiste mais
elle est due aussi à la rencontre entre
l'artiste et son public se rencontrent
cette rencontre peut se faire qu'avec le
respect mutuel de chacun pollution
sonore aussi dans les restaurants depuis
quatre ans après three l'ip boulevard
saint-germain demande à sa clientèle de
ne plus recevoir d'appels à table
le respect de la tranquillité de son
voisin c'est une question de bienséance
d'une question d'éducation et ça marche
plutôt bien
reste encore quelques esclaves du mobile
pourtant même eux ne seraient pas de
style à plus de discrétion
c'est dans le mode d'emploi pour
vraiment que je lis ça m'a l'air pas mal
donc vous prête à faire un effort pour
que ça fasse moins de bruit oui tout à
fait une solution existe bien c'est le
vibreur soit incorporé soient ajoutés
aux portables si vous portez l'appareil
sur vous vous recevez une petite
vibration le problème c'est le coût
très peu d'appareils honte un vibreur
incorporer ce que ça ferait monter le
prix de base de l'appareil donc c'est à
vie voire c'est paraître
et effectivement quand on achète un
appareil par exemple à 290 francs et
convaincre 200 francs de vibreurs c'est
un frein et si la meilleure solution et
l autodiscipline
ce serait faire l'économie de nouvelles
réglementations que certains souhaitent
déjà
un barrage réussi hier soir entre la
navette spatiale américaine endeavour et
la station mir une rencontre à 383 km
d'altitude qui a permis à andrew thomas
le septième et dernier américain à
séjourner dans la station pour un voyage
de quatre mois échange de poignées de
mains deux heures après cette opération
entre les deux commandants de bord qui
ont alors ouvert les écoutilles du cese
de connexion pour finir le tout sur un
dîner partagé avec les 10 membres des
deux équipages
à nouveau paris pour guy delage qui
avait réussi on s'en souvient a
traversée de l'atlantique avec des
palmes en 1995 aujourd'hui l'aventurier
s'est lancé dans une nouvelle aventure à
haut risque ce matin au large de sumatra
dans l'océan indien il a quitté les
rivages à bord d'un petit vaisseau sous
marins pour dérivé pendant deux mois à 7
mètres sous la mer l'objectif observer
la vie sous-marine valérie gage est
parti à la dérive l'étrange des sceaux
d'un naufragé volontaire
ce matin guy delage 45 ans a quitté son
flotteur pour rejoindre 7 mètres plus
bas la capsule en forme de poisson qui
doit abriter pendant 70 jours si tout va
bien déjà il doit faire le ménage car
des parasites se fixe sur la coque
soumise aux caprices des vents et des
courants
le vaisseau n'est pas motorisé en
surface un flotteur abrite les réserves
d'eau les compresseurs d'air et les
moyens de communication
relié par six câbles la capsule est
lesté par un contrepoids de 12 tonnes
guy delage ne sortira que deux fois par
jour pour se ravitailler sur le flotteur
et effectué des prélèvements de plancton
le reste du temps il le passera ici dans
cette cabine à 33 degrés et 100% du midi
c'est pour observer la vie sous marine
l'idée de cette mission scientifique
m'est venue il y a trois ans pendant sa
traversée de l'atlantique à la nage à la
vue des coryphène c'est daurade qui
l'accompagné moi je veux monter sur mon
rat d'eau
pour me reposer donc ou pour dormir
j'avais effectivement
une frustration celle de ne pas savoir
ce qu'ils continuaient de se passer en
fait sous l'eau avec les cauris fun avec
le banc en fait dans lequel je vivais
lorsque je nageais
partie du nord-ouest de sumatra guy
delage ne sais pas où l'odyssée se
terminera il risque une collision avec
un cargo ou un accident de plongée dans
le monde du silence il veut se glisser
sans bruit gageons que même les poissons
en serons médusé
contre la folie des hamburgers cette
manifestation destinée à donner le goût
de la bonne cuisine française aux
enfants un concours où de nombreux
écoliers créer leurs propres recettes
comme ici à toulouse sous la houlette
des grands chefs reportage muriel la
saga olivier combe
candé se font herbe mijote la cuisine de
demain
premières vérités des chefs petits ou
grands la fraîcheur et la qualité du
produit
et fraîcheur à l'intérieur
et il ya des poils
comme si elles viennent juste de sortir
après quelques emplettes nécessaire
crocker des croquants sont entrés en
cuisine le défi réaliser leur recette
sans tricher et sans regarder dans les
livres attention le thème imposé les
légumes ça change un peu du fast food et
c'est franchement mieux pour grandir
comme une belle plan ils font des plats
avec un petit peu de ciboulette un petit
peu d'estragon avec des légumes des fois
un peu oubliée avec de la betterave
alors que la betterave commenges à
l'école on voulait jamais mangé
polissage d'étrave c'était on n'en
voulait pas eh bien ils font des choses
avec donc c'est un petit peu un retour
aux sources et le trouve ça très bien
ici les grands sont au service des
petits surtout pour éviter brûlures et
coupures mais seuls les maîtres queux
connaissent leur mission par coeur c'est
quoi ta recette une fraise league man
avec des aubergines découverte des
poivrons beaucoup de choses le temps
aussi réglementée 1h30 pour en faire
tout un plat la purée elle est un peu
raté les liquides
en avance qu'est ce que tu as fait l'un
un cake aux légumes ça s'appelle jingle
cake joignez aussi est dans les temps
c'est l'heure de soumettre son oeuvre au
jury ce que je m'efforce de juger c'est
plus la rai hôtellerie magie nation
l'histoire qui vont raconter que la
presse technique pas de petits plats
dans les grands donc mais des savin et
des gestes ancestraux qui semble-t-il
ont encore les faveurs de la génération
hamburger
nouvelle victoire en ski pour les
français ce fait le front du vilar prend
la troisième place dans le slalom géant
de cortina d'ampezzo en italie pour la
coupe du monde de ski la médaille d'or
revient à l'allemande martina iphone
[Applaudissements]
77e édition aujourd'hui du prix
d'amérique une course mythique avec les
meilleurs trotteurs créé en 1920 cette
manifestation hippique a présenté des
cracks comme le fameux ourasi quatre
fois vainqueur de cette épreuve
aujourd'hui c'est une jument française
qui l'a emporté devant tous les étalons
laurent frédéric bollée frédéric bonnet
et le genre d'après midi tout aussi
épique qui piquent et pas la peine de
tendre la perche pour la saisira grand
rendez-vous de grande musique et grande
parade le prix d'amérique où le derby
des trotteurs c'est la plus populaire
des classiques 30000 spectateurs 400
journalistes 18 concurrents au départ
avec aussi une histoire de famille dans
la famille dubois voici les fils jockey
est entraîneur il ya aussi le père
propriétaire
tout ce petit monde retient son souffle
les favoris se sont eux comme on dit ils
ont la pression du moment
d'accord on laisse travailler monsieur
dubois qui seront au départ et on
s'intéresse aux anonymes aux passionnés
ici personne n'a oublié les idéal du
gazeau où les ourasi le cheval c'est
aussi une religion même faire veto
pour travailler dans l'élevage et j'ai
vite j'ai fait médecine je suis moins
heureux de travailler avec nous sommes
arrivés mais surtout le prix d'amérique
c'est la mecque du pmu 200 millions de
francs de paris c'est le record de
l'année il faut dire que les trotteurs
ont des carrières plus longues que les
galopeurs les valeurs ils sont donc plus
sur les gains aussi alors on joue
beaucoup en espérant un coup fumant
sur le
t3 eh bien c'est raté le vainqueur du
77e prix d'amérique c'est une jument au
nez et à la barbe de tous les étalons
dryade des bois numéro 7 l'emportent et
bat même le record de l'épreuve côté art
14 contre un c'est une surprise en tout
cas honneur à jos verbeeck qui remporte
là son deuxième prix d'amérique
consécutif le driver belge la victoire
est française tout le monde est content
en tennis le français cédric pioline ces
prêts sortir par le tchèque petr korda
aux internationaux de tennis d'australie
tête de série numéro six cordes à
l'emporter 6 4 6 4 3 6 6 3 devenant un
style premier joueur à accéder aux
quarts
rentré très médiatique pour johnny
hallyday qui assure lui même la
promotion de son nouvel album le rockeur
français cette fois ci plutôt sombre
dans ses interviews et l'image de ses
nouvelles chansons entrepris une séance
marathon d'autographes de marseille et à
bordeaux sans oublier paris louis carzou
didier dans
huit heures du matin aéroport du bourget
une longue très longue journée de
promotion commence pour johnny hallyday
parra
dacca
première étape marseille est sur la
piste de l'aéroport le premier phare
je te remercie
et pour tous ceux qui n'avaient pas la
chance de travailler à l'aéroport ce
jour-là un concours était organisé avec
une chaîne de magasins de disques seuls
les 100 premiers acheteurs de son nouvel
album aurait le droit de rencontrer dix
d'or
pour une dédicace un petit mot échangé
un instant de bonheur
un curé on dirait s'en aller
j'ai perdu ma l'ordre est tombé c'est
vraiment lent mac une petite heure plus
tard décollage pour bandeau moi c'est la
première fois que je que je me déplace
comme ça en province pour pour faire des
dédicaces
je pense pas qu'il ya requip d'ailleurs
qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens qui ne le
passe à part les hommes politiques la
plupart du temps moi je sue ça normal et
je trouve ça plutôt bien que nous ont dû
placer que l'on aille vers les gens
salomon kalou et que c'est pas toujours
à sens unique
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est des larmes de joie oui
18 heures retour à paris où l'attend
encore plus de 5000 personnes sur les
champs-elysées une apothéose pour clore
cette journée de promotion qui aura
nécessité deux avions privés une
vingtaine de véhicules et près d'une
centaine de personnes pour la sécurité
et une mobilisation à la hauteur du
personnage exceptionnel comme sa
capacité à émouvoir 38 ans après ses
débuts celles et ceux qui l'ont connu
alors
comme celle qui le découvrent
[Musique]
découverte avec le festival mondial du
cirque de demain sur la piste de jeunes
talents animés par la même passion avec
notamment ce groupe d'acrobates
brésilien qui enflamme le public gérard
dalmas joseph basse tic
sur un air de carnaval ces neuf
brésiliens viennent montrer au festival
mondial du cirque de demain la nouvelle
tendance de la piste l'acrobatie brut
issu de la rue
maquillage soigné pour la seule fille de
la bande de gamins sortie des femmes
hélas miséreuse de rio renforcée de
quelques sportifs olympiques du
trampoline le tout sous la houlette de
la patronne alice et ses ultimes
consignes
mettant en scène du numéro un français
héros bidon vrai grand du cirque c'est
lui l'âme du célèbre archaos pirro
explique pourquoi ces athlètes sont
équipés comme des pugilistes antique
l'idée c'est d'abord d'abord quelque
chose de simple parce qu'ils ont des
corps magnifique pour qu'on les voit
bien et il ya une inspiration don qui
vient de dumas coulé parce que c'est
l'histoire d'un enfant qui à lui tout
seul a vaincu une armée et qui n'avait
rien simplement que même pas sont
valides et des costumes c'est de marquer
les extrémités parce que comme il tourne
beaucoup en faisant la croma si en
faisant le trampoline donc on a marqué
l'extrémité de la tête les bras et des
jambes un mental donc faire qu'ils se
moquent de la pesanteur rigoles du
vertige le tonus de ces gosses fait
exploser les performances du genre pour
eux ce festival du cirque de demain est
le vrai tremplin la carrière triple saut
périlleux où colin a trois très
difficile à plusieurs sur un filet de
caoutchouc difficile aussi pour un
groupe de rester groupé surtout quand
les artistes viennent d'horizons sociaux
différents selon roberto l'équipe est
désormais sous des
décide ça aide beaucoup les
après quatre années ensemble tant qu'il
commet des frères on sent les premiers
acrobates se lançait il ya 5000 ans en
voici les eric et ses nouveaux
voltigeurs de l'audace les cirques aux
notes
la mode toujours dans l'actualité avec
le salon du prêt-à-porter féminin l'an
2000 faisait fantasmer les couturiers
dans les années 60 trente ans plus tard
alors que la mode avec toujours une
longueur d'avancé s'intéresse à
l'automne hiver 98 99 que se passe-t-il
dans nos vestiaires la réponse avec ce
film et elle est dédiée rancoeur
le tout géométriques graphique le blanc
immaculé les tenues de cosmonautes dans
ces années là les années 60 pour la mode
le futur c'était une obsession
il existe en matière de mode un style en
2000 courage y est sans aucun doute pour
quelque chose
[Musique]
courrèges paco rabanne et quelques
autres nous laissait présager d'un
troisième millénaire décoiffant éclatant
est en tout cas différent
l'enjeu pour nous c'était en 60 on l'a
vécu à cette époque là et comme on a
l'habitude de faire toujours des
collections en avance de toute façon ne
vit jamais dans le temps présent
et la mode de l'an 2000 et l'a
pratiquement à portée de main dans ce
[ __ ] une mode moins rutilante moins
conquérante en somme plus discrète que
tout ce que les visionnaires il ya 30
ans avait pu imaginer qui correspond le
plus à cette idée de l'an 2000 c'est
l'engouement à l'heure actuelle de la
console des consommateurs pour la haute
technologie cachés dans les vêtements
cette technologie fasse de plus en plus
souvent par des matières comme le
stretch pour quelques grammes de confort
supplémentaire mais la modernité de
demain c'est aussi le mélange des genres
paréo de rapper sur pantalons de ville
ou jupons de ballerines à porter avec
des chaussures de sport histoire de
bousculer les conventions
[Musique]
la femme en cette fin de siècle a
conquis le droit d'afficher ses charmes
sans pudeur mini jupe fendue haut on
combine est la guerre réservé au seul
regard intime à vrai dire aujourd'hui
plus rien ne choque mais notre plus
belle conquête c'est le vestiaire de
l'âne on a le droit de se travestir sans
vergogne ils st laurent a osé briser le
tabou dans les années 70 depuis le
pantalon on ne serait plus s'en passer
[Musique]
et puis cette information politique qui
nous parviennent à l'instant dans
l'élection législative partielle de metz
marie jo zimmerman candidate rpr udf est
arrivé en tête au premier tour avec 33
75% des suffrages devant marie anne
isler béguin candidate du parti
socialiste et des verts qui recueillent
23 72 % des suffrages ce premier tour a
été marqué par un taux d'abstention
particulièrement élevé 71% ainsi se
termine ce journal je vous en rappelle
les principaux titres chapelle ardente à
montigny le bretonneux pour un dernier
hommage aux victimes de l'avalanche le
guide de haute montagne qui encadraient
la randonnée a été placé en garde à vue
à deux millions de fidèles à cuba sur la
place de la révolution pour la messe
célébrée par jean paul ii homélie
politique du saint père la contre
attaque de l'île clinton qui réunit un
cabinet de crise alors que la presse
s'arrachent les images du président avec
la jeune stagiaire
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinez une semaine plutôt froide et
peut être ensoleillé 22h55 james bond
dans moonraker avec roger moore demain à
7h50 dans les 4 vérités penseuse laborde
recevra pierre joxe le président de la
cour des comptes de mme amateurs vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
fin de soirée sur france 2
[Musique]